continuez sur cette ut culture avec la
culture sur saint quentin en yvelines
et si vous aimez les titres de jean
jacques goldman et michael jones le
concert proposé par arte beauty est pour
vous le guitariste franco gallois est le
premier artiste à se présenter à se
produire pour la toute jeune association
d'événementiel et c'est ce samedi 17
septembre là aussi à thoiry michael
jones et interprétera les plus grands
titres du trio goldman michael jones et
fred et carole fredericks ainsi que de
nombreux titres de son dernier album on
écoute bénédicte rouxel elle est membre
de l'association et michael jones
l'artiste et après on écoute un extrait
sur le concert de michael qui était à
gif sur yvette
on a repris contact puis sérieusement
avec vie et on a commencé un petit peu a
discuté de et si tu venais sur toi
riches
il nous a dit pourquoi pas et dans ces
cas là comme on venait juste de monter
l'association
hong a demandé s'il voulait bien être le
parrain de notre association
donc si le premier gros concert pour
l'organisme la chaîne pour moi fut mon
bac à sable
c'est à dire que c'est là où je m'amuse
c'est pour ça que j'ai arrêté de faire
des sales gosses parce que j'ai envie
vraiment de m'amuser et donc je ne fais
tu de la scène à partir de maintenant
hors délai
et 1
je
sans témoin
ça
quel débat
g